it is so wonderful to see you today you
know asking the question how are you
such a load of questions these days but
the question is how are you coping you
know I have good days and bad days to be
honest there's just so much heaviness
going on you know the pandemic really is
starting to get to me it seems like it's
getting worse and not better thought
it's a lot it's a lot I'm sure
everybody's looking at us like what is
happening in America I don't know I
don't know either you know it's just
it's all so surreal but you have a way
of using your voice and yesterday I was
sitting there without no distraction and
listened to black like me and I have to
tell you I had tears in my eyes because
I felt the pain and unfortunately so
many people can relate to this song and
he wrote this at a time when armed
robbery things happened to him what does
he represent to you well he represents
my brother my dad my nephew and I lived
in majority white neighborhoods growing
up and that could have been my family
jogging through that neighborhood I had
that song my mom called me and she was
like we need a message of hope right now
I was like mom I played you that song a
year ago I have this song and I just I
didn't know how to go about releasing
something like that because with my
label you know being an artist if you
think it would be a release a song and
it's not there's like a thousand people
you have to go through so before we
released it it came out so suddenly like
the Friday before blackout Tuesday I
called my manager and I was like Eric we
really need to talk about at least start
the discussion of releasing black like
me especially in this time come Monday
morning I wake up I've got a so many
phone calls and they're like we're gonna
release black like me tomorrow and I was
like there you have it that's huge that
the fact that they were willing to do
that like that says a lot of
change as well because in your lyrics
you say I'm all grown up and nothing has
changed and just what you're saying now
there is these little steps that
recovery are making change happen how do
you define change
well I define change by seeing people
actually listening there's so many
conversations over the last month or so
seeing so many black people and people
of color getting a chance to be heard
and a lot of times I feel that people
thought it was just a bunch of noise and
now people are actually listening and
that to me has changed
that's a Hulett people are finally
getting a chance to be heard and to talk
about these issues that have been going
on since way before we were yeah to even
really comprehend them and I love the
way you are so open on your platform you
have so many followers you have so many
fans dedicated fans and you're using
that voice or educating them how was the
reaction when you start talking about
black lives matter movement well you
know of course you get your occasional
parens and Kevin's that say I have
something to say but the overall
response has been absolutely beautiful
when I released black like me my room is
right over there and I stayed in my room
literally the entire day because I was
terrified about the reaction which is
crazy to think that I'm doing about
releasing a song that's my truth there's
nothing more why why were you so
terrified well I think my label as well
as my self was scared of the push back
that I would miss you the hate that I
would receive and I'd still get it but
it's not nearly as bad as I thought it
was at one point the label had even
discussed about possibly getting
security for me and were too angry about
it and that terrified me I was like what
you want security for me like I'm just
I'm just this black girl from Texas why
do I need security you know and that
really really terrified me so I was
expecting this pushback and even when I
wrote the song a year ago I remember one
of the producers Nathan Chapman said to
me I think we just wrote one of the most
important songs of your career and it
might make it really angry so it was a
constant thought that this could
possibly be that and it wasn't it was
actually the exact opposite which is
great for me that has changed yeah you
talked about how everything is so heavy
right now and there's so many trigger
points when you're on social media if
you're watching the news as he said
Brianna Taylor he's no justice for her
at this point you talked about George
Floyd how do you mentally take care of
yourself knowing that you have to
continue this this conversation you know
I have to put social media down I have
to do a lot of just spinning I have four
animals that I spend a lot of time with
writing helps a lot I've really dived
into writing a lot I've got a whole set
up here in LA that I can remotely write
and and get this stuff off of my chest
music really does feel so much and just
spending time with my husband like it is
so heavy you know so I have to
completely take the time to just step
away sometimes and take care of myself
yeah you really do have to step away and
I'll have to give you kudos because
you're a country artist in an industry
where it's hard enough for a woman to
succeed we talked about the radio play
where there's not enough for women to be
on radio and here you are bringing out a
song like this and you talked about
being terrified about it but do you feel
now free almost to be able to speak your
truth in country music I'd ever since I
finally got over the fear of the
pushback for me it's the reason why a
lot of country artists don't really
speak on a lot of matters is how to fear
that they're gonna be canceled out of
this format and that's the way they make
their money that's the way they take
care of their families and for me it was
like I've already hit rock bottom I
can't go any lower I'm just gonna speak
my truth and it doesn't matter what
anybody says because I'm speaking in
I'm not angry about it I'm just speaking
the truth like look it's hard love color
look it's hard for white women and
something needs to change and I
literally will openly say that white
women are being discriminated in country
music just as much as any black person
and sometimes even more and it's
important that we have these
conversations we have to become
uncomfortable to incite change we have
to it's the only way and that's why I've
become free because I want to see change
I really really want to see change
whether anything happens for my career
on I want to see change talk about white
women it brings them it makes me think
about lately Lady Antebellum changing
their names to Lady a the Dixie Chicks
changing it to the chicks and putting a
protest song out there is that consider
the change you need in country music yes
that's that is that's a start I still
wanted more women have major careers I
want to see more women be able to have
Stadium tours and arena tours where they
can take other women out with them that
is the change that I want to see that
I'm starting to see I'm seeing more
women start to get number ones on radio
back to back but that's that's the
change that I want to see seeing more
people like Jimmie Allen get success
seeing's people like myself I would love
to see more women of color whether they
are black whether they are Mexican
whether they are Asian whatever I would
love to see that that is the change that
I would like to see has anyone from the
country music world reached out to you
after releasing the song yes actually a
lot of people have Kaylee hammock has
been one that's been supportive even
Dave from Lady Antebellum reached out to
me to support me there's been a lot of
support in that sense Margo price yeah
Tennille it's nice yeah mr. Newlin what
was it like growing up in Texas well it
was a lot of church a lot of time in
church when I was vacation bible school
whether it was Sunday school whether it
was choir rehearsal
Church that was a lot of church in Maya
Texas Mike and I lived in the country I
lived in off of gravel roads like my
grandmother she lived so deep in the
country that the streets didn't have
names they were numbered
and that was my life my grandmother was
a huge Dolly Parton fan so next my roots
VHS tapes on the back of the door there
were Kenny Rogers and Dolly Parton VHS
tape even in southern movies that was my
life I loved you know being an artist in
in an industry like this where a lot of
girls are looking up to you what is your
advice going forward now in 2020 with
these changes with less fear we still
have the fear less fear going forward my
advice to women that are pursuing a
career in country music or any music
career whatever your ideas are great
ideas do not let all of these people get
in your head and mess with your artistry
because that happened to me and as women
when we grow up we're taught to respect
our elders and majority of the people in
authority are male and there are elders
and a lot of times we tend to cater to
what they want versus what we want and
we must realize that you are the talent
you are the artist
you are the future so stand up for what
you believe stand up for your music
stand up for your artistry and don't
stop don't stop standing up for yourself
and speaking your mind you are so
beautiful and your voice is so beautiful
and thank you for everything you're
doing and absolutely you are changed so
thank you thank you for what you're
doing
you